buenos días buenas tardes buenas noches
aquí steve y por la primera vez que mi
vida voy a visitar a méxico un país país
que no conozco
estamos en contacto con julio en la
ciudad de mexico que vamos a organizar
una cena un encuentro
cerca de mi albergó de mi hotel le voy a
poner aquí la dirección de mi hotel pero
el sitio el lugar es julio que va a
decidir pero será el 9 de marzo 9 de
marzo en méxico si hay gente que quieren
participar que indiquen aquí para que
podemos contactar con vosotros el 9 de
marzo en la ciudad de mexico
con mi mujer
estaremos en mexico de 26 de febrero
hasta el 13 de marzo del 26 al 2 de
marzo
en san miguel de allende del 2 al 6 de
marzo en guanajuato y después del 7
bueno 6 7 de marzo hasta el 13 en la
ciudad de méxico es por eso que vamos a
encontrar el 9 de marzo en la ciudad de
mexico
espero voy a encontrar a muchos de
vosotros bueno hasta luego
en mexico gracias